une époque où l'on écrivait ses devoirs
avec de lancre une époque où les classes
n'étaient pas mixtes
durant trois semaines la maison de
covile de voisins-le-bretonneux se
téléporte au début du 20e siècle pour
montrer au public ce qu'était une école
en 1900 la salle dans laquelle nous
sommes est typiquement l'école 1900 vous
avez son poil qui est sur la droite plus
l'ensemble des pupitres qui sont devant
nous et qui représente tout les ages
scolaire activement depuis sept ans
jusqu'à présent pour présenter ces
objets d'époque le club des
collectionneurs des yvelines et la ville
de voisins-le-bretonneux ont noué des
partenariats avec le musée de l'école de
chartres ou encore le musée de
l'éducation du val d'oise à gonesse en
1882 la loi jules ferry rend
l'enseignement obligatoire entre 6 et 13
ans un enseignement pour toutes et tous
qui utilisait parfois d'autres méthodes
pédagogiques vous avez sur le tableau
une morale par exemple où chaque jour
les enfants qui arrivaient lisait la
morale du jour l'instruction civique
était d'actualité
la formation le respect de la patrie
était aussi d'actualité
donc ces thèmes effectivement de
l'époque sont aujourd'hui un peu on peu
disparu au profit effectivement de
l'enfant qui doit apprendre s'épanouir
seule une exposition visible jusqu'au 18
décembre et qui saura réveiller le jeune
écolier qui sommeille en chacun de nous